we're gearing up to the local elections
what are you expect him to see well it's
difficult obviously when you're just on
the eve of those elections to state with
definitive certainty what that could
happen the experts has been well
advertised uh rattings and Thrasher the
sort of gurus of polling say that they
expect the themselves to lose about a
thousand seats up to a thousand and the
worst case scenario not that that's not
the unfinished predictions and it is
challenging you know all the points
about the the point in the lifetime of
this Parliament and some of the
challenges that we had as a government
last year I think make it tough but
we've got some very good candidates
we've got um a very good record in local
government on everything from
maintenance of our roads the amount of
money that we've devoted to potholes to
keeping Council taxes low to making sure
that when for example big planning
decisions are made that conservatives
make sure that we protect the green belt
and Safeguard the environment and of
course when it comes to recycling as
well uh conservative councils have a
great record when it comes to waste so I
hope that the good work of conservative
councils is rewarded at the polls
tomorrow potholes and bins you know we
were in a local election Bingo season
and certainly we know that those are
votes are coming up when you guys start
talking about those things
um I spoke to kirstama who said that
actually the conservatives should be
making gains in these elections 2019 he
says was the second worst set of results
ever Theresa may apologize and a few
weeks later resigned and that was the
end of her and he has got a bit of a
point hasn't he I mean you say look the
experts are predicting up to a thousand
seat losses but they're predicting that
because of how badly you guys are doing
in the polls no I think uh again Sakia
will say one thing one day and another
thing the next in order to you know uh
uh try to well it's been quite
consistent in in saying about your I
think I don't think the labor leader has
been saying that conservatives should be
making gains very often he does it
because he he tacks With The Wind in
order to you know we use a classic
politician I'm getting very confused by
the direction we're going here I'm
asking you about the reason that you are
setting to to lose seats at the election
is because of how badly you're doing it
and indeed you you put it in the context
of Kia's Spin and you know he'll say it
as he always does because of the
political advantage of the moment that
he's seeking but the broader point is
that
um we are uh facing uh a challenge uh
after what was a very difficult year
last year and the one thing I would not
want to see is the good work of
conservative councilors on the ground
affected by the backwash of what
happened I also think that there is a a
recognition that with a new prime
minister in Rishi sunec with the focus
that he's put on uh Harvey inflation
reducing debt growing the economy
cutting waiting lists and of course
stopping the boats that people will I
hope uh be ready to vote conservative
tomorrow and ready to see us deliver
over the course of the next year or 18
months it's going to be quite tough in
some of the sort of traditional blue
wall should we say some of the places
like where you represent in Surrey yes
do you think it's gonna be a difficult
night in those kind of showers well I
think that there are challenges
everywhere um and I think specifically
then I think that uh we know that there
will be uh some uh opportunist political
parties and movements that will seek to
uh uh generate or catalyze some of the
challenges that we've had in the past in
order to try to do uh to take uh control
of some local authorities
um but ultimately I think that the
record of conservative councils the
efficiency that they've shown I I hope
will be rewarded more broadly though I
would say as the secretary responsible
for local government there are people in
all parties who do believe in
contributing to their communities so I
wish all the candidates well but I
really hope that people will reelect
conservatives and in Surrey the
conservative uh uh Council record has
been one of uh to my mind you know
superb delivery in my own constituency
which is one of the most attractive
places in in Britain to do business
um we I want to talk about housing you
mentioned their sort of green belt uh
you've also said previously the housing
market is broken yes and we desperately
need more homes to bring ownership
Within Reach of many more people are you
going to be taking on the nimbies well I
think that it's wrong to characterize
people as nimbies I think it's insulting
to use a phrase like that I think the
the critical thing is we need to go with
the green of uh what people want people
do want new homes but they also want new
homes which are beautiful they want the
infrastructure alongside them the
investment in schools hospitals and
roads they want to retain Democratic
control and they want homes that are
environmentally uh situated in the right
locations that's why the green belt is
so important I'm interested to hear you
say homes that are beautiful there which
obviously everyone would prefer a
beautiful home but I'm just wondered
about you know where the line is you
know you recently blocked Barclay homes
from building houses in Kent because
their generic Suburban what's so bad
about generic Suburban doesn't the prime
Authority need to be getting houses no
the most important thing is to make sure
that we have homes that are quality
dwellings that people can take pride in
and also equality dwelling but generic
Suburban right no well first of all that
is a specific planning uh application
which is now being judicially reviewed I
can't go into the detail but there's a
very good letter in the times today
pointing out that actually
um the design code which was adopted by
the local community has to be complied
with and it is important we all believe
in local democracy on the eve of local
elections but local democracy is honored
but more broadly if we simply
concentrate on the quantity of homes
built and don't concentrate on quality
what we risk creating are the slums of
the future you and I both know about
some of the recent tragedies that we've
had in poor quality rented housing poor
quality social housing and in poor
Quality Private rented housing so we
need to make sure that homes are high
quality that they contribute to a sense
of community and the polymer high sell
them cheap approach that we saw in the
1960s has now unfortunately led to
people being in homes which are just not
fit for purpose
rental market there and one of the
one of the people getting the home homes
is because they can't afford to save up
for them right so you know just looking
in London a third of your wage now most
people's wages are spent on rent rental
prices up 15 on last year what are you
doing about it we're introducing new
legislation it'll be out next week it's
a renters Reform Bill
um and it will change the way in which
the relationship between landlords and
tenants work providing tenants with new
protection which should ensure that they
are better protected against arbitrary
rent increases are you not worried on
the building homes front as well what
scrapping targets is going to do no I
think that it's a misnomer to say that
we're scrapping targets we we still have
a commitment to 300 000 new homes every
year and what we've done is we've
provided incentives for local
authorities to set achievable targets
taking account of uh the importance of
protecting the environment and if local
authorities do not set an appropriate
number of homes that are built then they
will find that their plans are overruled
by the planning inspector but it's a
more sensitive nuanced pro-environment
pro-democracy approach
um I want to talk to you a bit about Sue
gray it's been a lot of focus on sugray
the senior civil servant who left to
become kiss Thomas Chief of Staff now
you work with her for many years right
so you know her more the most is she a
woman of Integrity totally so do you
have any concerns about her appointment
yes I do and they relate to kirstalmer's
role um the key thing is kissed armor
could share with the public with Akbar
and indeed with the cabinet office
details of all of his contacts with Sue
and all of his team's contacts with Sue
and others he has chosen not to do you
think his silence condemns him it's
unchivalrous it's untrustworthy it's
wrong the responsibility of stormers at
the same time though you say she's a
woman of Integrity yes you it therefore
would I would imagine believe that she
wouldn't do anything that would be you
know breaking the rules or against the
rules
um our political adaptive political
editor Sam Coates saying today that the
first Contact between Sue gray and timer
was in October I mean that's after Boris
Johnson that's after partygate what's
the concern surely you do talk to
somebody before giving them a job well
the person who could clear this up as I
say is kirstenler um uh he is he is uh
the elected figure the public figure
with the responsibility of having
initiated uh uh this approach and having
taken this decision
um uh he should come clean his failure
to do so suggests to me that he has
something to hide it's up to him
now it's been a pretty difficult time
for civil service the scrutiny of the
Sue gray appointment there's been of
course the focus around the Dominic Raab
report as well the man at the top of the
Civil server some case in the papers I
think more than I can remember anyone
else in that job is that a sustainable
position for him yes I think it's simply
the case that um the the media
environment in which we live
um and I don't think it's just a fact of
life means that there is more Focus
sometimes on individual characters at
particular points and there will be
individual people who will
um uh be you know in the in the pit of
the spotlight of news
he is in the spotlight and it's the
decisions and the advice that he's given
that has come under question you know
whether it's Sue gray whether it's Nadim
zahawi uh whether it's Boris Johnson
is this sustainable that he's getting
this constantly in the Press constantly
his decision has been picked over and
questioned yeah I think it's it's uh it
is sustainable and I think it's wrong to
concentrate on uh civil servants in this
way
um I think that the inevitable focus on
whoever was cabinet secretary is a
consequence of the turbulent political
times through which we've been living so
whoever had been cabinet secretary
um would have found themselves because
of a you know a period when you've had
three prime ministers in a relatively
quick succession would have found their
role as the the prime minister's
principal policy advisor among other
things uh held up to the light so he was
a victim I guess of the chaos and the
conservative part is what you're trying
to say I wouldn't say that I think that
we've been living through very turbulent
political times
um but I think that
um uh the cabinet secretary and other
permanent secretaries uh strive to do
their best for the elected government of
the day of course there's going to be
scrutiny of them but my own view is that
we as elected politicians should be
grateful to them for the work that they
do
um and we should appreciate their
commitment to Public Service uh
are you pledging allegiance to the king
this weekend oh yeah definitely what's
your plan well I'm very fortunate as a
member of the cabinet or certainly as a
member of the cabinet at the moment
um to be invited to the coronation and I
shall uh it's a it's a it's a great
honor and it's it's a moment when our
country comes together it is on the one
hand a a a moment of religious and
historic significance but it's also a
chance for us to recognize that
um our history it has been a history
where we've achieved enormous things
made great progress because there are
also symbols of continuity and so this
country you know the home of the NHS the
country that defeated the slave trade
and defeated fascism we did all that
because a constitutional Bedrock was
Secure the more secure your home the
further you can Venture and in that
sense our royal family the monarchy is a
symbol of that security so I'll be
celebrating the institution as well as
also remembering both the service of a
late Majesty the queen but also the
commitment to so many great causes of
the king not least the environment
clearly a bit of a royalist then are you
gonna you've got any Street parties
you're getting a quiche out what's the
uh
um uh later in the day
um uh I'll be with a few friends and yes
we probably will go mad with the
coronation quiche